[Music]
all right so I wrote this book for my
daughter okay so should I refer to you
as New York Times best-selling author
Channing Tatum or just chanting
I love Dr Seuss
modern day did you ever think that you
would be doing this no absolutely not
that's so cool I didn't think I'd be
doing any of this I would love there to
be someone to go and find any one of my
English teachers and ask them if I was
the least likely to be published much
less a New York Times bestseller they
would probably guarantee you that I
could barely like string together like a
like a fully formed sentence you battle
dyslexia oh yeah correct oh yeah and
then I started acting you start reading
a lot like your half your job is reading
and reading and reading so I got a
little better so maybe you should reach
out to an Old English teacher I would
love to they would be like what I doubt
they even remember me I was you know
Florida seriously I have a Philly
Channing Tatum's a little memorable I
don't know I'm not sure about that
whatevs whatevs sure we love him as
Magic Mike but Channing Tatum's also a
children's author and celebrating his
third book The One and Only sparkella
and the big lie out now the story is
inspired by his daughter Everly who just
turned 10 this week double digits dude
what are you doing celebrate uh we just
went to Six Flags so we kind of did it
early are you ready for those teenage
years no I don't think anybody's ready
for the teenage years I soak up the love
you're getting right now because you're
going to be the most hated dad soon I've
heard it's like aliens come down and
just snatch your kid away and then bring
it back like you know around 22 or so
yeah yeah
sparkella you know go with us through
those younger years into teenage years
into young adults um I think for maybe
the books she might stay the same age
um but we'll see with the movies we're
hopefully gonna do a little animated TV
series so we'll see with those you know
I don't know what
the greatest joy in reading my daughter
I would have to all these voices and she
was like this lame dead can you just can
you just read it normal and I'll be like
I'm like given the best performance of
my life right now like it's awesome
but it was really great though she
didn't want me to do it at home because
I think she was just trying to control
it a little bit and um then when I did a
reading at her school she was like do
the voices what are you doing like why
are you holding back yeah like I'm like
I think she's a director in her future I
look I hope but guess whatever she wants
to do I'm here for is everyone here know
what Eli is you've said that this might
be your favorite book so far why is that
it's a little more complex they're
experimenting with lying at this age
what's different between make-believe
and then a lie and I remember a story of
my daughter's very first like big kind
of like yucky feeling lie what was that
like she stole a little toy car uh from
from school and and she was just sick
about it and then she told me and I
could just see like the whole weight
lift off of her like just as like just
the uh like the yeah she just became
like like her again isn't that just
amazing like as a father I can only
imagine the evolution of little Everly I
mean are you learning do you feel like
just as much as she is along the way I
might be learning more well do you run
ideas by Everly hey hon do you think
this would be a good topic and you want
to do the first reading of my first
draft I get her to help me with the art
well she's got great taste yeah she's
got great art she's going to Fashion
Camp uh this coming week no way a little
designer well you designed one heck of a
fort for her I'm I'm a good four Builder
I can do that that's one of my skills it
was impressive he has little tea lights
and everything inside we've done
drawbridges we've done moats we've done
all different kind of things OMG my
child's a dream's right there